star wars battlefront 2 has a new star
fighter assault mode and we finally got
to see it in action at Gamescom this is
a full match at the Imperial shipyard
map above the planet of fawned or and
you'll catch some glimpses as special
vehicles like the slave 1 and Millennium
Falcon + Darth Maul's invisible
infiltrator ship be sure to subscribe to
GameSpot to see a whole lot more the
rebels need to take down the Imperial
defenses but the turrets and the
Imperial light cruisers need to be
destroyed and the Empire all they have
to do is just make sure they take out
the rebel scum that's right just like
that right there boom and a wing getting
blown of this guy by Narwhal days so
this is a new ship that we've never seen
before in Star Wars Battlefront the tie
bomber what is this class and what does
it do yeah it's on you bum a cloth it's
heavily armoured and home for the teeth
really great for taking down objectives
they can see here like you were saying
it is a tank it does a lot of damage one
of my favorite abilities that it has is
the multi rockets at it that it's able
to shoot multiple rockets at multiple
targets yeah if you use those two
abilities at once you can have five
missiles in the end five missiles look
at it just tearing through these x-wings
these a Ling's it's just getting the job
done now here's a another ship that
we've seen before in battlefront but
it's it's been reworked it's a little
different this is the a wing and it
falls within the Interceptor class how
does it work problem well it's it is the
intercept applause it's fast in that
agile it was I wasn't agile enough
though and partially getting taken out
it's a bit of a gloss cannon it is most
definitely a glass cannon now we have
the wildling which is the bomber class
but for the rebels how is it a little
different from from the tire to the tie
bomber that's right on its tail it's I
don't even think you know he's there oh
whoa no he's attacking for the rebels
it's a y-wing he's doing a bombing run
but no more now Rob we've seen a lot of
ships flying around the x-wing and the
TIE fighter definitely iconic ships in
the Star Wars universe
where do those fall into all this so
they're a balance class they're quite
good at dogfighting also they can take
on objectives
but so they're kind of flexible flexible
but not flexible enough Tommy T taken
out these x-wings
snowing ham right now again in that tie
bomber he's just he's going to work
areas Narwhal David no he wasn't the
white wing and he just kept rammed by a
Thai bomber sorry Dave let's not cool
not at all now the rebels are definitely
doing a lot of work ran out they're
melting through those Imperial light
cruisers those as you can see it x-wing
like you said before it's there to take
out those objectives and the x-wing is
just melting through it 50 percent left
on this first phase it looks like this
inferior like cruiser is definitely
gonna go down boom here it goes see you
later dude he's gone
now why when you said was there to take
care of the objectives he's doing this
bombing run he's definitely just tearing
this Imperial light cruiser apart and
they're going second one down that's two
two yeah they did they're dropping
behind to the second phase Rob how does
the second phase work in Starfighter
assault overfond or the rebels need to
get into this tunnel and blow up full
full shield projectors that are still
protecting the dog okay so oh ouch still
have to watch out for those signatures
yeah yeah the sulla alright Rob so we've
been talking about all these ships we
haven't really mentioned the hero ships
and here's our first site at Darth
Maul's scimitar what is so unique about
this Sith Lord ship well there's the
reason you haven't seen him very much
because he's invisible
he's a stealth ship I see okay and now
here's another hero ship poe dameron's
black one x-wing
Rob what's so special about this this
excellent what makes it so different
well this black I got that part what's
different about it well pose a natural
leader so he's got an area of effect
shipping help his friends out around him
now he also saw another hero ship on the
wheel to jump back into that that is the
Millennium Falcon piloted by Han Solo
and Chewbacca now here is another iconic
ship in Star Wars universe Boba Fett's
slave one
what do we have to watch out for with
this downy ownership pretty much
everything it's late one he's got
concussion missiles to go ion cannons on
a seismic job seismic charge what's so
dangerous about a seismic charge Rob
well in this closed environment it's
gonna get a lot of kills so it does a
big old area effect first hopefully well
that's it that was it so he's definitely
doing his job he's using that that came
that mind he is objectively trying to
trying to blow everybody up apart that's
trying to attack those shield generators
now here we go we see jack frags piling
Darth Maul's scimitar he is just tearing
everyone apart and see who is taking
some damage to be cloaked
he's using his his targeting computer
and he also has those torpedoes to his
advantage student great what he's doing
really really well right now just
tearing everything apart he's going
through is all going those rebel scum
but you have to watch out for star wars
battlefront updates he's in the white
wing taken him out he does takes out
Darth Maul's scimitar and also goes
after that Imperial bomber as well now
there's not much left on the shield
projector but we do see Han Solo's money
Falcon for the first time up close and
personal
Rob what is whatever you have to look
for with the Millennium Falcon
you can see right here hunt Falcons
taking an all full of damage and that's
what he's great at he's a brawl one
brother indeed he's a big tank he's got
it looks like the entire Imperial fleet
chasing after him he is just doing what
it takes should be doing a growing high
bring those guys through the objective
trying to give his his buddies a chance
to to take out the
objectors the seismic charge going off
again that the wildling is doing of the
bombing runs taking out the shield
projector so they can move on to the
next phase you have two percent left
there's fifty reinforcements left
Narwhal Dave using black one to chase
after slave one as they are going
through do you thing and diving around
the shield projectors unfortunately
doesn't look like he's gonna be able to
take out slave one the rebel should
still have this the rebels are things so
they've got forty reinforcement slabs
two percent left in the steel protecting
I think they're gonna get it now we're
getting a better look at Han Solo's
Millennium Falcon and see he's got some
really cool abilities at his disposal as
well but we got Battlefield France doing
what seems to be the last and final
strafing run on the shield projectors he
does end up taking them out taking the
rebels to the third and final phase now
Rob let's do a quick recap we have phase
1 the rebels had to destroy the Imperial
light cruisers then in phase 2 they had
to destroy the shield projectors and now
we get to move on to phase 3 what's that
all about the Star Destroyer is still
getting power from the dog so the rebels
need to disable the power couplings
leaving the reactor core vulnerable now
it wants the reactor core is vulnerable
is it always available for destruction
or key or do they have to do anything
else they've got about a 30-second
window to do with much damage as we can
and then the and then the couplings will
then come back that's right
all right well battlefront updates again
just doing immense work with the
Millennium Falcon will be that'll watch
out for this group of tie bombers that
look like they're they found Trey they
their day they smell blood in the water
can be going after the Millennium Falcon
I don't want to give a battle for an
updates I don't want to tell him the
odds but he's gotta watch out right here
he is a tank but two bombers on him I'm
not so sure I mean that's about 10 rock
I mean I'm not the bit the best at NASA
I think that's ten rockets that he has
to watch out for
tie bombers are staying on his on the
rear of the money falcon they keep on
getting those locks with multiple
missiles going after him I don't think
he's gonna be able to make it he's our
buddy doing pretty well great job but
unfortunately no the William Falcon is
taken out of the fight but Narwhal Davis
right behind those enemies tie bombers
trying to take them out he is an ace
pilot looks like he's doing a lot of
work right now as its he's using those
dual proton torpedoes taking out the
first high bomber he's getting a little
bit of damage using that Astra next to
repair the x-wing and then the weapon
over to overcharge where he's able to
fire all of those lasers at the same
time for the same time yeah and
unfortunately he was trying to go after
slave one but it wasn't able to do it
the power couplings have been disabled
the rebels are doing a lot of damage to
the reactor but it doesn't affect enough
they have been re-enabled and it looks
like the rebels got to go back and try
to get those suckers off over to be
they'll get another Jones J will to get
another chance
that Millennium Falcon is doing a lot of
work now this is something we haven't
really seen yet rob is those those four
vets that have been kind of floating
around doing some damage to the Empire
let's talk a little bit about those well
I think that was the problem the Empire
didn't see them in phase one and now
they're in Phase three and it could be a
lot of trouble for these poor vets are
ai-controlled ships and they are able to
help the rebels push through the
different phases
that's right they'll creep through the
levels doing damage to star fighters
they have objectives you know we're back
on board with Narwhal Dave who's in the
x-wing and he is just he is an amazing
pilot he is handling that x-men so well
Rob you guys have done a fantastic job
is rebuilding the controls these
starships yep we rebuilt them all from
the ground up on a all unique every ship
that is so awesome again back on board a
no-name Falcon taking out those cinder
shirts it looks like the power couplings
have been disabled again the reactor
core is going down and that's it it's
been melted away the Star Destroyer is
gone victory for the rebels
[Applause]
you
[Applause]